what is the most mind-boggling thing
that happens when a star dies well I
mean it's a really awesome light show
right incredibly beautiful when stars
die they go out with a bang I mean who
dies and has more energy when they
explode than the whole time they were a
star that's kind of amazing to think
dying stars are ultra cool the idea that
the core of the star can collapse from
the size of the earth to the size of
London in a second is amazing and it
bounces off itself that's what makes it
explode just like fell on itself very
awkward but also very beautiful the fact
that what's left over is one large giant
atomic nucleus at its centre absolutely
mind-blowing
we have white dwarfs neutron stars and
black holes that are just like weird in
so many amazing ways that's why I'm a
physicist today because I love the weird
that's also why I've had so many
relationship problems why do dying stars
and tree Gus so much
I think dying anything intrigued us for
better or for worse our Sun seems the
same every single day it seems like it'd
never evolve but stars have a lifetime
like everything else and how they die
sometimes determines what else is born
the Sun seems so a tunnel
it's been burning for four and a half
billion years but it really will burn
out someday and everything that this
planetary system is are begone some
people say that it's as sure as the Sun
Rise well you know what one day the Sun
will rise the entire universe is a cycle
of life and death it might not be the
happiest body but it's something that
kind of grounds up some tells us we
really should appreciate life for the
moment
you